the coastline extending roughly 15 miles
around the town is a shark attack hot
spot there have been as many as 20 shark
attacks in a single year which is a
tremendous number for such a small area
in fact since records began this tiny
region has seen a shocking total of more
than 220 shark attacks that means
roughly one out of every 25 attacks
worldwide happens here earning the area
a terrifying claim to fame New Smyrna
Beach has been nicknamed the shark
attack capital of the world
it's a reputation no one in this tourist
haven wants people ask me every day are
there strout's out there we really can't
tell what the cause is when people get
bit out there a lot of people will not
come here because of that this problem
must be solved for the sake of
beachgoers here and across the nation
it's really important to identify the
factors that are associated with a spike
in shark attacks because we have a
chance of using that knowledge to keep
each goers safe throughout the world so
what makes newsom erna
so different why are humans more likely
to be bitten here than anywhere else on
earth perhaps a clue can be found within
the species responsible for Emma's
incident
the vast majority of attacks worldwide
are conducted by one of three types of
sharks bulls Tigers
or whites but based on the pattern of
Emma's wounds experts believe she might
have been bitten
by a black tip black tip sharks are
found in warm coastal waters across the
globe they often feed in large schools
and are easily recognizable by the black
colored markings on their fins and they
grow up to eight feet long which means
they're large enough to take down a
human dr. Stephen Kajiura has been
studying black tips along Florida's
coast for almost a decade each year he
takes to the skies to research this
species the taking part in one of the
most awe-inspiring marine phenomenons in
the world this footage shows what we've
captured by doing an aerial survey you
can see all those little dots every one
of those is a shark
just in that narrow band we're seeing
literally tens of thousands of sharks
this is the black tip migration the
largest shark migration in the United
States there are hundreds of thousands
of these black tips making this
migration along the coast every year
they come down to spend the winter here
in Florida because the temperature is
ideal for them many different types of
sharks migrate annually in search of
food warmer waters or a mate most travel
alone or in small groups and they
typically do so in deep waters but the
potential problem for beachgoers is that
the hordes of black tips prefer the
shallows
these sharks hug the shoreline they
might be doing that to stay away from
predators bigger sharks so we have
thousands of them so close to shore
right along the beach while the bathers
are anytime there is an influx of sharks
in an area the chance of a run-in with
humans also increases so is the large
number of attacks near New Smyrna simply
the result of this large number of black
tips inshore
the answer comes down to timing the
black tips past New Smyrna from
September to November then again in
March and April and only about half of
the attacks on record took place during
those months
so the migration may play a part in some
of the incidents but it's not the whole
story
[Music]
you